the rights activists say at least 8,000
people have disappeared after being
arrested by security forces in
indian-administered Kashmir this data
covers a period since the beginning of
the conflict in 1989 but it is disputed
by the Indian government activists say
India's Public Safety Act allows
security forces to detain individuals
with insufficient evidence for a trial
for the past 17 years par veena
a hangar has been waiting for her
missing son to return my name is / veena
a hinga I'm from Kashmir I'm 65 years
old my son was taken away by security
forces and Army in 1990 since then I've
been looking for him at 3 o'clock in the
morning the security forces raided he
used to go for studies at his cousin's
house he used to either stayed there for
the night or come back home that night
he was staying there when they raided
they thought it was the house of the
local rebel he was dragged out into the
road where they had their vehicles he
was only wearing his undergarments they
removed his cousin's clothes and made
him wear those his cousin was released
but he was taken away he seed these
piles of files and court orders but
nothing has been achieved the case is
still pending
sometimes if anyone knocks at the door I
feel like he has come home someone may
have told him that his mother is waiting
I couldn't bear it
but I decided that I have to carry on
with my life as I have to look after my
other kids as well he used to take care
of me like a daughter does my own
daughter was very young then he used to
buy dates for me on the night of laylat
al queda on the 10th of every month we
mark it as a day of grief mothers crying
for their sons half widows crying for
their husbands waiting for their loved
ones to return we assemble here because
we get some kind of Solace we share our
pain and grief we feel like we'll
remember our son
if we don't do this we remain very
anxious I'm a victim and I know how
other victims feel why do I the only
difference is that those who have been
killed in this conflict their parents
have a grave to visit we don't have any
no solace we are restless we're waiting
for our sons to return is lambda bread
I've grown old now since 1990 I've seen
people getting killed and even today
people are getting killed until they
solve the Kashmir issue this bloodshed
will continue